-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for watching at home.
Thank you.
-Come on!
-Let's get to some news, here.
Guys, today Elon Musk said
he needs more details
about how many spam accounts are
on Twitter
and, until then,
his $44 billion deal to buy
is temporarily on hold.
[ Audience oohs ]
Yep.
Temporarily on hold.
When they heard, even Verizon
customer service reps were like,
"Oh, he's not coming back.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, no."
Elon might be on to something
with the spam accounts.
It's a little odd
that Chef Boyardee
has 800 million
followers, you know.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Elon Musk's
purchase of Twitter is on hold.
In a statement, he said...
Then Twitter CEO
Jack Dorsey said...
[ Laughter ]
Then Elon said...
And Dorsey said...
[ Laughter ]
And Elon said...
And Dorsey said...
[ Muffled ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, we'll see what happens.
-Wow.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Hey, this is cool --
On Sunday night,
a total blood moon eclipse
is going to rise over the U.S.
[ Oohs ]
Yep, a total blood moon eclipse.
It's like every "Twilight" movie
title rolled into one.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Very exciting, a red moon.
Or, as Mars put it...
[ Slow clap ]
"How original."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Guys, get this --
apparently, inflation has caused
a lot of consumers,
including young people,
to do less online shopping
and now malls are attempting
to get young people
to go shopping again,
but I think they're trying
a little too hard.
Look at this commercial
I saw today.
[ Vuvuzela blasts ]
Online shopping is dank.
But you know what's always
savage? Malls.
-[Electronic voice reverberates]
-That's right.
Forget Prime.
We got a fountain full of dimes.
-And pennies.
-So, yassify your drip
at all the tope stores, like...
[ Laughter ]
Spencer Gifts.
-No parents allowed.
-Plus...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, and if you're actually...
hit up that Jamba.
[ Laughter ]
And did I mention
the escalators?
[ Ethereal tune plays ]
[ Laughter ]
So don't be a simp.
Get some free samps
-[ Screech ]
-at Panda Express,
make Sbarro your sbae,
and go straight-up...
-[ Screeching ]
Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Hey, listen to this -- the USDA
has issued a public health alert
over ground beef
from Whole Foods
that could contain
plastic fragments.
[ Oohs ]
On the bright side,
since it's Whole Foods,
is at least organic,
grass-fed plastic.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, customers knew there was
plastic when it felt like
the roof of their mouth
had stepped on a LEGO.
[ Laughter ]
But Whole Foods
isn't worried now.
They're selling it as a Real
Impossible Burger, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, this is cool --
I saw that Google just unveiled
prototype glasses
that can actually
translate languages for you
in real time.
[ Murmuring ]
Basically, someone could speak
a different language
and the translation
will appear on your lens.
Take a look at this.
It's real.
♪♪
-You should be seeing
what I'm saying,
just transcribed for you
in real time,
kind of like subtitles
for the world.
-Isn't that cool?
[ Murmuring ]
Yeah.
-Wow.
Not only that, apparently,
the glasses can also translate
what people actually mean
when they say certain phrases
to you in English.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Yeah.
For instance, if someone says...
It translates to...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, if someone asks...
It translates to...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally, if someone says...
It translates to...
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's pretty spot-on.
It's good.
[ Cheering ]
Hey, I read
that Southwest Airlines
is spending $2 billion
to upgrade their planes
with faster Wi-Fi,
charging ports, and larger
overhead bins, yeah.
Meanwhile, not to be outdone,
Spirit Airlines
is adding windows.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some entertainment news --
I saw that Christopher Walken
was just cast
in "Dune: Part II."
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
He's playing the emperor,
alongside Timothée Chalamet
and Zendaya,
who are coming back,
so I thought it'd be fun
to go around the studio
and see who could do
the best impression
of Christopher Walken in "Dune."
Alright, here, I'll go first.
[ Clears throat ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ As Walken ]
The spice must flow.
[ Applause ]
Felt good.
-Yeah.
-Higgins.
Higgins, let's hear your best
"Dune" Christopher Walken.
-Alright, ready?
-Yeah.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ As Walken ]
Fear is the mind-killer.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Oh.
That's actually better
than I thought.
James, let's hear your Walken.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ As Walken ]
If you walk
without rhythm...
[ Laughter ]
...you sound a lot
like my friend --
[ Sputtering ]
[ Laughter ]
...Smooth Jeffrey.
We've been friends
since he was 30 years old.
Now, he's 31 years old.
[ Laughter ]
He's a really bad dancer.
But he invites me to go
to the clubs with him, anyway.
[ Laughter ]
He said he won't be my friend
anymore, if I don't.
Let's face it --
I'm not exactly in a position
to be choosy
in the friends department.
Smooth Jeffrey's signature move
is called The Flop.
[ Laughter ]
I --
I'd show you how
to do it right now,
but I'm not wearing
the right kind of pants.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Smooth Jeffrey.
-Alright.
Moving on,
[ Laughter ]
got some sports news.
Some sports news.
[ Laughter ]
-What was it called, The Flop?
-I don't know what he --
-He started going off --
-He started going off
on his own tangent.
-Smooth Jeffrey.
I don't know what's going on.
[ Laughter ]
Here's what we did --
James rehearsed
a different bit earlier today.
We just added those cards,
just to see if he'd read them.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's making us laugh.
[ Cheering ]
[ Claps ]
Rehearsal,
it was like two lines?
-One or two.
[ Laughter ]
It's like eight cards.
-Yeah.
Guys, moving on,
some sports news --
Rich Strike,
the 80-to-1 long shot horse
that just won
the Kentucky Derby,
is skipping the next race
in the Triple Crown
and coming back
for the third race.
[ Murmuring ]
Yeah. Yeah.
Honestly, there's nothing
more relatable
than exercising for two minutes
and then taking a month off.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's a little suspect,
though, right?
I mean, it's not a good sign
when you have a shocking win,
then suddenly need
to lay low for a while.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
a company called Plufl
has created the world's
first human-sized dog bed
and it costs $400.
[ Laughter ]
Here it is.
[ Ohs and applause ]
-Wow.
Honestly, I can't tell
what's more annoying --
the bed, the price,
or that I just had to say
the word Plufl.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Plufl.
Yeah, it sounds like
a dating app
for single dogs in your area.
[ Laughter ]
Can we see it again?
Yeah. For the low,
reasonable price of $400,
you can live just like your dog.
[ Laughter ]
Very easy to use.
Just get in,
turn around three times...
[ Laughter ]
...turn around three more times
the other way,
lie down,
and dream about rabbits.
[ Applause ]
We have a great show tonight.